Welcome everybody. It's great to see you at this pediatric brain tumor session.
So for those of you who I don't know, my name's Richard Gilbertson.
I'm based at the University of Cambridge.
And I'm delighted that we've got two other speakers here
today, Shriram and Mariella, who I'm sure everybody
knows. What we've done is put together a session today... Oh, hi Joey.
Joey's a PhD student in my lab, sorry.
It's the only time I get to see him. So,
we've put together a session which is focused on a particular kind of
brain tumor, which many of you will know about, supratentorial ependymoma, which is
driven by this odd fusion. Although I think the principles involved
will be applicable to other tumors other than
supratentorial ependymoma. But we've also chosen a mix of talks.
So the first talk, which Mariella will give, is about
three-dimensional structures, particularly as it relates to genomics and thinking
about the origin of these diseases.
Then Shriram is going to talk about metabolomics and how the metabolic
functions are affected in brain tumors.
Then I'm going to present something about the immunology of
supratentorial ependymomas as they relate to tolerance of
brain tumors, but I think this, as you'll see at the end, is also applicable to
other brain tumor types. I'm not going to give any more introduction than that
because it's better to give the time over to the speakers.
So without further ado, Mariella, it's great to see you. Thank you for coming.
All right. Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for staying this late in the conference and coming to our session.
We were talking about how a few years ago it wouldn't have been possible to
fill a whole session with talks on supratentorial ependymoma, so we're very
excited to lead this session together.
No disclosures. Our field of pediatric oncology
has really long hypothesized that pediatric cancer might have, and
replicate many aspects of normal development, but in an aberrant way.
The mutation, or fusion in many cases, might happen very early during
development, but then despite this transformation, the cells
oftentimes retain their plasticity and retain their capacity
to differentiate along the predetermined lineages.
And that's not only interesting, but we are hoping we can also derive some new
targeted treatments from this knowledge, as well as predict and
understand treatment resistance better.
So my lab studies brain tumors through this lens of development.
As I just said, we apply single cell genomic
technologies to fresh tumors from the OR at Boston
Children's and colleagues, and then by comparing it to normal
development, try to infer developmental
trajectories onto that, and also look into spatial technologies
as I will present a little bit later, and understand how these hierarchies and
trajectories are made and sustained.
But then also we want to apply chemical and
genetic perturbation to cell models from these patients,
to move the field further towards therapies, and that's really the end
goal of my lab and many of the labs here in the room also, to
derive new therapies for our patients.
We've applied these principles to a variety of
pediatric brain tumors and AWA brain tumors over time.
Most of the work from our lab is on gliomas, and today we'll talk about
ependymomas, a very distinct and somewhat enigmatic brain
tumor kind. This tumor arises
across the entire CNS axis, and was first described
by Dr. Bailey in 1924, so over 100 years ago.
And then nothing happened for 50, 60, 70 years until then Richard
came on stage and did a lot of beautiful work together with Michael Taylor, with
David Ellison, Eric Holland, then Shriram, Stefan,
Christian, and Marcel to really look into the biology of these
tumors further.
They are all
characterized by these ependymal rosettes that you see in the middle,
but interestingly, and despite all these many
studies over many decades, we have not to this date found any
chemotherapy that touches this tumor at all.
So to this day, we use surgery and radiation to treat these patients
at diagnosis and even at recurrence.
Of course, ependymal tumors can be even further characterized rather than
the old H&E classification. We are now using
molecular neuropathology, in this case DNA methylation arrays, to
further dissect and classify all of the pediatric and adult brain
tumors. And ependymomas are shown here in red.
All these red different islands on this tSNE plot of DNA methylation are
all ependymomas. And you can see this large variety of
different subtypes, and I've circled for you the supratentorial ependymomas
we'll be talking about today. What is so interesting about these, that
even on this DNA methylation tSNE map, they cluster very far
away from each other. The YAP fusion-driven ependymoma is on the very
top, and the main cluster in the middle, which most of them are
driven by CEFTA fusions, I'll talk about in a little bit, and the
very right out subependymomas we won't be talking about so much today.
So the first goal of this study in my lab in collaboration with
Christian Paidla, Johannes Goyo, Varun Venkataramani,
was really to assemble a cohort that was able to span all these
different clusters and subclasses of supratentorial ependymoma by
itself. So it took us a really long time, a few years, to get these fresh and
frozen tumors from the different
centers. And we wanted to especially look at this spectrum because the
prognosis for these patients, it's rather different.
YAP-driven supratentorial ependymomas here in this
green have the best prognosis and most of our patients survive,
whereas CEFTA/RALF-driven ependymomas have about a 50%
overall survival over time. And a few of the newly described
clusters, we're still waiting for very good outcome data.
But it seems like the cluster three and four in particular might be a little bit
worse in terms of outcomes.So we assembled this cohort
of a total of over 60 patient tumors in the end.
This is a busy slide just to show you that we did
indeed cover all the different clusters and subclusters as we were
trying to, but of course, the majority of our tumors analyzed here
is part of the canonical SEFTR relay fusion class.
I should also say on the previous slide that we are very proud that through our
Ependymoma meetings in Cambridge that Richard and Michael are
organizing, we were able to get together with colleagues, discuss this plan
for this publication, and were able to co-publish at the same time
with Steve Max and Ben Neen's group in Nature last month.
All right, so our study was then, once we had this cohort, was aiming
at looking not only at the gene expression profiles of these different
clusters over time, but also what their spatial patterning might
look like, and
new for us as a lab, we wanted to look at the cell state morphology and
phenotype, asking what does it even mean, and go beyond this descriptive
state.
But we started with single-cell genomics, single-cell RNA sequencing in
this case. And again, as I told you earlier, in our lab, we always
compare then these tumors to early human cortical development.
It's very important to use human in this case, as the human cortex
undergoes a very rapid expansion of the cortex in early pregnancy.
You can see here a graph that
I derived with my good friend and colleague, Tom Novakowski at UCSF, who
studies normal brain development, where he studied in the human context,
the single-cell variety of brain development, going from the left from a
single cell layer of neuroepithelial stem cells
all the way towards the end of the first trimester, going towards
early radial glia that first make neurons, and then about
pregnancy or post-conception week 15, 16, 17, this neuronal
glia switch happens, and then you start making glia, one of which is
our ependymal cells in the bottom right.
So we took the single cells from the patients, projected it onto this atlas first
in bulk, and indeed saw that the best prognosis
tumors, supratentorial YAP1 at the bottom of the
bubble plot,
seemed to project to later developmental stages during
pregnancy, whereas SEFTR relay was somewhat in the middle, and some of
the probably bad prognostic new cluster SEFTR
tumors had matched to very early in first
trimester pregnancy.
We then looked at the single-cell profiles of all of our patients, and
did NMF analysis to see what programs are
recurrently present across different patients.
And we're very interested to see that some of the biggest clusters are very
early embryonal stem cells. The cluster on the very
left on the top is neuroepithelial-like, meaning that those are cancer
cells that very much resemble this neuroepithelial cell layer that I showed you.
That's the first layer of the neural tube development.
In addition, we also found differentiated tumor cell states, including
ependymal-like cells, radial glia-like cells, which Richard and
Michael had shown as a potential
cell of origin for some of the supratentorial ependymoma subtypes.
And then also neuronal-like differentiation in the few cell states that were
really hard to pinpoint and we called embryonic neuronal-like or just
embryonal-like.
These states then, when you look at the different clusters of disease, the
different molecular clusters are differently distributed.
Again, on the very right, you can see the good prognostic YAP
fusion-driven ependymomas that
contain almost exclusively these green ependymal-like differentiated cells,
whereas SEFTR relay fusion-driven tumors have a variety of all the
cell states present, and SEFTR cluster three looked very different in terms of
having more immature embryonic-like cells present than the other
clusters. This can also be shown or represented
in a cell state plot where we plotted the two
most undifferentiated cell states on the top,
neuroepithelia-like in the left upper corner, embryonic-like in the right upper
corner, and the two differentiated cell states at the bottom,
ependymal-like on the right and neuronal-like on the left.
And then you can ask, what are the different clusters? What do they look like?
And indeed, the molecular clusters do seem to have a
different hierarchy or trajectory that they follow,
especially when you zoom in on the most extremes.
Again, the YAP fusion-driven
tumors on the bottom are almost all differentiated as I
showed you. SEFTR relay tumors seem to have a lot of this
neuroepithelial-like stem cell, but then differentiation towards both
ependymal and neuronal-like cells.
And this
unique cluster three had no neuroepithelial stem cells, but rather just
embryonic or almost no neuroepithelial stem cells, but a lot of
these embryonic-like cell states.
We then wanted to look at how these cell states,
how they arrange themselves in a 2D and 3D pattern, and used the
10x Xenium platform that we fed with
gene profiles derived from our single-cell profiles directly.
So from the same patient, derived single-cell profiles, and then looked at
differential expression, and then added that to their normal
human brain panel that Xenium has pre-made, then subjected
our either fresh or FFPE
SEFTR relay tumors that had already had RNA sequencing done on
them, and then performed this technology to look at the cell
states in the slide.
And this is what it looks like. This is one of our SEFTR relay patients.
We were very happy to see the very beautiful resolution
of this technology, and the fact that we were able to
find all these cell states that I had described earlier in the single-cell
space, but now here on the slide, also normal
cellsAnd what we can also do with this platform is
at the end of spatial transcriptomics run H&E, and even
you could run up to four cycles of immunofluorescence to ask how do
your cell states, is your calling reflected in
H&E or any other stain? In this case, I'm pointing out the ependymal
rosettes that Dr. Bailey had described over 100 years ago.
As you can see, indeed, the platform picked up ependymal
differentiation of these cells. So that's interesting, but more of a sanity check
that the technology really works in terms of finding these cell states.
You can also see for the aficionados among you, an
endothelial,
a little cluster of a blood vessel on top of these three rosettes.
And then we started asking these questions of, are these tumors organized at
all on the global level? And taking the entire tumor piece that we had
access to into account, and indeed found a dichotomy of tumors.
Either they were structured, like shown on the left, some degree of
structure,
using an algorithm that Itay Tirosh has developed and published in
a "Cell" paper in 2024.
Or tumors also came in this disorganized fashion, as shown over on the right.
And when we did multivariate analysis to ask what exactly
determines what
makes a spatially coherent or organized tumor, it
was the mesenchymal-hypoxia cell state, the presence of which
alone determines that a tumor then later can
become more spatially arranged. And this is interesting
because also this was a finding of
Itay Tirosh's and Mario Suva's work in an adult glioblastoma, where
the presence of mesenchymal and hypoxia really led to the
spatial arrangement. So we see the same here in ependymoma.
You can then also start asking questions of who is next to whom
in terms of cell types and cell states, what are smaller spatial
niches rather than this global organization pattern?
That's something we are very actively working on as a lab.
And just to show you some of the first analysis we've done.
Interestingly, many of these cell states like to be with themselves,
so more of the same, plus one or two best friends.
So the normal cells, neurons in this case, like to hang out with themselves.
Immune cells like to be close to blood vessels.
They like to cluster around endothelial cells.
And the neuroepithelial-like, so this very early stem cell-like
state, seems to cluster with all the other cell states present in
those tumors.
And now I'll show you the last part that I'm very excited about to really ask, what
does it even mean, these cell states?
Are they a mere reflection of distance from a blood vessel,
distance from hypoxic mesenchymal, or do they truly have a
different function within these tumors?
Because making these cell states comes at a cost, so what does the
tumor get out of it?
In order to address this question, we of course, couldn't do that in patient
samples and needed models from these patients, grew them in multiple
different ways,
namely as neurospheres in non-serum stem cell media, or
adherent on laminin, or in co-culture with normal
human or rat astrocytes and neurons, or as PDX.
And then always projected these single-cell
profiles back on our patient cohort to ask, to what degree do
our cultures reflect what we actually see in patients?
And that's shown over down at the bottom, a little bit busy also, but I wanted to
appreciate that the orange dots, those are the cells coming
from cultures that were either grown as a PDX or co-cultures,
were the only ones that went all the way down this hierarchy that I had shown you
before, a trajectory of differentiation.
So if you want to see ependymal and neuronal differentiation of these tumor
cells, you cannot just grow the tumor cells alone.
If you grow them alone, then you enrich for the stem cell-like state, which makes
sense. That's what we enrich for. But if you want to see differentiation, you need
more sophisticated ways to grow them.
And so we used those two PDX and co-cultures grown, as I said,
either with rat or human neurons and astrocytes, labeled the tumor cells in
red,
and then in the in vivo system, used two-photon imaging together with Varun
Venkataraman in Heidelberg with a cranial window to ask,
when you follow these cells over time,
can you determine different morphologies?
With the end goal then of projecting that back onto the cell states I had described
earlier. And indeed, both in the PDX in vivo
as well as in these co-cultures in vitro, we saw four
different morphologies in the time that we observed the tumor.
We saw either naked cells that we called having zero tumor
microtubules on the left, then cells with one to three short tumor
microtubules,
cells that had many, but certainly more than three short tumor microtubules,
and then cells that had one to three very long projections
over on the very right. And again, this is shown in vitro as well as in vivo.
As a first step to ask which of the cell states they could be
reflecting then, we did immunofluorescence stainings on these mice and on
these cultures after
in vivo imaging or in vitro imaging,
and saw that indeed the naked cells, the zero TMs and the short TM
cells, were positive for stem cell markers.
So we thought they could be neuroepithelial-like
tumor cells. Whereas the cell that had the many projections, and I'll show
you a video of them in a little bit,
had early expression of CCDC40, which is an
early ependymal marker. It was the only cell that had this
marker present. And then these long projection tumor cells
had a few markers of early neuronal development present.
So we thought this could be the neuronal-like cells.But I wanted
to look a little bit more into detail, having the spatial technology in the lab.
So we grew tumor cells labeled here again in red on the
Xenium slide with co-cultures, with normal human neurons.
Those are IPC derived. And then applied the Xenium technology
spatial transcriptomics on the slide.
And you can do this beautifully because then in the end, you can determine who is a
tumor cell or not by overlaying the IF profile as shown here.
So all the red cells are tumor cells.
You can see that a lot of the normal cells, the normal neurons, are in the
background, of course, not lighting up in red, but still having the same
transcripts present. And then you can even do subcellular
localization of transcripts and look at transcripts present in the soma
in this case, and at the protection of this tumor cell.
And indeed, those transcripts that were present were the ones that helped us
define the neuronal-like
cell state in supratentorial ependymoma.
So what I had shown you in the slide before with IF, we could indeed
confirm here, and this was the case for all the different cell states
I had shown you.
And then most beautifully, we can follow them over time and see how they
move and behave in the in vivo context.
And this is what these neuroepithelial-like tumor cells do in the
brain and in vitro co-cultures. They either don't move or they move very
slowly in a linear fashion over time,
whereas the neuronal-like tumor cells have this saltatory
behavior, which is reminiscent of early neurons in the developing human cortex,
which means that a projection goes first and then the cell nucleus is dragged
behind in a jumping fashion. That's how early radial glia cells
jump when they grow to the external layers of the cortex.
And then this is this ependymoma-like glia cell that I showed you before earlier.
These guys never moved. They were stationary and just extended and retracted their
many fibers over time.
Looking more at these neuronal-like cancer cells, they really truly mimic immature
neurons in multiple ways, not just with the saltatory behavior, but
also with branching. You can see here one of the tumor cells that spans many
hundred microns, extending through the brain of the mouse.
They also have these protrusions that we know are from early neuronal development,
where the goal in normal development is to look for nutrients or gradients that
they then follow for their development,
and also retraction, which is a phenomenon again seen in normal development.
When they don't find what they're looking for, they retract their
projections. We measured this
migration speed, as well as the migratory patterns and proliferation shown
summarized on this slide. And again, this is just showing you more
quantified that the neuronal-like cancer cells are really the ones
that migrate the fastest.
They are the ones that have also very special migratory patterns, like the
saltatory behavior, as shown in almost half of these tumor cells.
But proliferation was the strength of the neuroepithelial stem cells.
So these guys that move very slowly or stay stationary, their
job is to proliferate.
And this is already then summarizing the entire talk.
I hope I've shown you first insights into the different gene
expression profiles across these different molecular subclasses of
supratentorial ependymoma and the new clusters that were identified recently,
which are starting to understand how they are spatially localized at
primary tumor diagnosis as well as relapse over time.
And again, the first few early days of defining what the phenotype in the
brain might be,
those glial ependymoma-like cells that stay stationary and extend
their little extensions, we don't know what
their job is yet, and looking into that as well.
And that's all to say that this is, of course, only the first step.
Now the next step is to look at what can we inhibit in terms of behavior
and what are the programs that we need to block to hopefully finally make
some headway for these patients.
And with that, I want to thank all the people in my lab who did this work.
Dawn Chang was my first grad student in the lab.
That was her paper,
shared with Sara Danielli, who is now a computational biologist in Basel.
I really want to thank our wonderful collaborators, Varun, Christian, Tom,
Johannes, without whom this work would have not
taken place in that shape. All the people in our brain tumor center, our
patients and families, and funders, and also again, Michael and
Richard, for really putting together an ependymoma working group.
We meet every year or every other year to discuss the latest progress and also
coordinate our work, which is really fabulous. So thank you all.
I think we have time for a few questions, Richard, right?
Yeah.
Yeah. Great talk, Mariella. Thank you. So I have one question.
For the subtype of with
YAP
overexpression cells,
do you by any chance look if those patients
have a better response to radiation therapy?
YAP major drive cells proliferation and
cell growth.
Mm-hmm.
So it probably responds better to radiation
therapy.
Yeah, those patients really do the best.
So sometimes, at very early stages, we only resect the
tumors, we meaning our surgeons. In some cases, we radiate,
but almost all of our patients survive.
So what the mechanism is, again, in detail, we haven't looked at that, but those
are the most differentiated tumors and the easiest to treat in our patient
cohort for sure.
Sounds great. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi, Mariella. Beautiful talk. Sneha Ramakrishna from Stanford.
You alluded to this, but I'm very curious what the cell state differences are
between primary metastatic relapse sites.
Mm.
Do you know the distribution of those different cell populations?
Yeah, it's a great question. We initially, in this paper, had a few
paired match samples from the same patient at diagnosis and later, but
we were not powered enough to make really
good statistical conclusions. What seems to happen over time is that the
mesenchymal hypoxia state increases.
That has already
been shown in glioblastoma as well.
And something also that Richard had shown earlier, that over time, these very
aggressive ependymomas become closer and closer to
glioblastoma. So that increases over time, but again, wasn't statistically
significant. The structure changes then, and we had
this good discussion also yesterday with the glioblastoma group.
We all think that probably at very early stages, which we didn't
have here,
before the tumor even becomes clinically relevant,
probably tumors have a hierarchy or an
architecture that follows normal brain architecture.
Then later they become more disorganized as they grow. That's when we see them.
And then at late stages, then hypoxia or another determining factor
comes into play and then drives this tertiary structure in many
ways. But other than mesenchymal programs, hypoxia programs,
we haven't seen... I was thinking it would be neuroepithelial stem cells that
increase over time, but it was only a slight trend and not
significant.
Thank you.
That's a great talk. I've got a couple of questions.
First of all, because you've got such an extensive group of human tumors now, and
you divide them into clusters-
Mm-hmm.
... what's the relationship between the types of fusion that you see and those
clusters?
It's a great question. So I thought when I started this work, there should be
different fusions in each cluster, but that's not the case.
So the canonical CEFTA relay fusion is also present in some of the other
clusters
sometimes, and there's no defining fusion per cluster, but
some stranger or more rare CEFTA fusions.
Okay.
So you cannot say that...
I was thinking it should be like a different fusion
makes a different cluster, but that's not the case.
So is it then a different stem cell with a particular
fusion
that makes this particular hierarchy?
I'm still not sure, but I'm hoping that some of Steve's work and some of your
work can help us elucidate.
Thanks. Then one other question then we'll have to move on.
And that is,
obviously the chromothripsis, which is on 11q, which drives
these translocations. Is there any clue from the
epigenetics or other aspects of the developmental hierarchy as to
why 11q is peculiarly susceptible to that?
I wouldn't know, but I think Steve is the person to ask, Steve Mack.
He looks a little bit into this.
Right. Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, so delighted to introduce Suram, who's going to talk to us about
metabolomics in ependymoma. Never thought that would happen. Thank you.
Good morning, everyone. Thank you so much.
I never thought it would happen too, Richard.
But really delighted to be a part of this beautiful seminar series that
Richard organized. And Mariela does such a beautiful talk.
It's really amazing. So I'm going to talk about metabolism,
and I'm going to tell you a story about how
potentially we can get rid of the fusion using a metabolic approach.
And this has been a huge challenge in fusion biology itself.
How do you actually target fusions?
And in this tumor, there's an indirect way, and I hope to
show you some data about that. So I have no disclosures.
And I first wanted to start by acknowledging the people who actually did this work.
This work was driven by a really brilliant and very talented
postdoctoral fellow, Shiva, and then, I'm very
honored and privileged to work with all these amazing grad students and
postdoctoral fellows in my lab. And this paper is coming
out along with Mariela's and Steve Mack's paper in "Nature," along with Michael
Taylor's
really beautiful PFA ependymoma in males androgen therapy.
So I also wanted to acknowledge various collaborators and founding
institutions, including Mariela and Michael and Richard, who gave us some of
the early tools to actually do this, and then various other collaborators at the
University of Michigan who made this work possible.
So I wanted to start with what Mariela just showed you, but stepping back a little
bit. So at the two ends of the spectrum of brain tumors, in
children, you see a lot of epigenetic deregulation, and this goes on the
concept that these tumors mirror developmental
abnormalities that Michael and Richard have talked about for a long time.
And at the other end of the spectrum are glioblastomas that have these very
traditional genetic alterations such as EGFR or
PTEN deletion or cell cycle regulators.
And I want to draw your attention to this middle group that happens in
young adults and during early adulthood, is the IDH mutations.
So these mutations are in isocitrate dehydrogenase 1, and these
introduce a paradigm of how metabolites can actually change
epigenetics in cells. So just to refresh your memory, wild type
isocitrate dehydrogenase 1, as the name suggests, dehydrogenates isocitrate.
It takes it and converts it to this metabolite alpha-ketoglutarate.
Alpha-ketoglutarate is then converted by mutant IDH into this
onco-metabolite D-2 hydroxyglutarate.
Now, D-2HG is structurally very similar to alpha-ketoglutarate,
so it can compete with alpha-ketoglutarate.
And one of the functions of alpha-KG is to act as a
cofactor for these really important DNA and histone demethylases.
So if it's competing with that, the demethylation reactions don't happen, and you
get this hypermethylation phenotype that you see in IDH mutant tumors.
You get both histone and DNA hypermethylation.
Now we also see this in other metabolites as well.
There's an isoform of 2HG called L2HG that's produced in
hypoxia that is more potent than D-2HG, and other
metabolites such as succinate and fumarate that also share structural
similarity with alpha-ketoglutarate.
In tumors with succinate dehydrogenase mutations or fumarate dehydrogenase
mutations, these metabolites outcompete alpha-KG and result in
hypermethylation phenotypes as wellSo just to introduce the
paradigm of an onco-metabolite, and we asked: Can similar
principles apply in childhood brain tumors?
So,
to
study this, we collaborated with Richard very early on, and this is the key
paper. Back then, ZFTA was called C11orf95,
discovered in 2014. And as already alluded in the discussion,
the most common translocation is between ZFTA and RELI.
And there's a series of beautiful work by Christan Pachtler, Steve
Mack, Richard, and
many others in the field that have shown different functions.
And ZFTA is hypothesized to be a chromatin
modulator, and ZFTA enables nuclear translocation of this
fusion. And the RELI portion triggers abnormal
ZFTA... I'm sorry, abnormal NF kappa B signaling that Richard has
shown.
So we wanted to ask if ZFTA/RELI is a really potent
oncogene, the field of cancer metabolism postulates that
oncogenes actually change metabolism, and this is not in a passive process.
The oncogenes actually rewire metabolism.
So we asked a very simple question.
Richard sent us these cells that had ZFTA or RELI fusion or empty vector
or other controls, and we just ran snapshot metabolites between these two
cell lines. And to our surprise, we actually saw that the top upregulated
metabolite was this metabolite called itaconate. So what is itaconate?
So itaconate has been studied in the macrophage biology field.
So when you take macrophages in vitro, and you expose them to LPS or
pathogens, they upregulate this metabolite called itaconate.
And this is done by metabolizing aconitate by this enzyme
called ACORD1. And it's really important for several macrophage
functions, including immune and anti-inflammatory conditions.
So it was surprising to see this in ZFTA/RELI tumors.
So if the enzyme that made it
is ACORD1, we wanted to see if this enzyme is upregulated in
ZFTA/RELI tumors. So we took this isogenic system that Richard
sent us. We have ZFTA wild type expressing mouse neuronal stem
cells or ZFTA/RELI, RELI wild type or empty vector,
and you can blot for RELI here. And the higher molecular weight
ZFTA/RELI fusion will show up as well, along with endogenous RELI.
And when we look at ACORD1 in this, you can see that ACORD1 is upregulated only
in the fusion conditions and not in the controls.
So if this is true, the cell should also make itaconate.
So we measured itaconate. So here on the y-axis, we're plotting itaconate
metabolite levels, and we're looking at two different conditions.
So here is the mouse isogenic system.
So here in purple is the ZFTA/RELI, and here are the control ZFTA wild
type, RELI wild type, or empty vector, and you can see that these cells produce
itaconate. We also have the human ependymoma
patient-derived cells. You have these two ZFTA/RELI, and here two
non-ZFTA/RELI, and you can see itaconate production in these cells.
So I showed you in the previous graph that if you introduce ZFTA/RELI, ACORD1 is
upregulated. So what happens conversely if you knock down the fusion?
So we created shRNAs against the breakpoint
fusion, and we transfected these cells with
the three different independent shRNAs, and you can see that you get variable
amounts of knockdown, and this knockdown is actually very toxic to the
cells. But what we also see is there's a reduction in ACORD1 levels.
So if you introduce ZFTA, the ACORD1 goes up, and if you knock it down, it goes
down.
So the next thing we did is to see if we could
validate this in patient-derived samples.
So we looked at ZFTA/RELI and
non-ZFTA fusions, some of the YAP1 fusions that Marila just talked about.
And then we did immunohistochemistry for ACORD1, seen in brown here
in tumor cells, and these are the
perivascular pseudo rosettes that Marila talked about, and you can see expression
of ACORD1 here and minimal expression in this YAP1.
We also quantified this, and we looked at the various molecular
subtypes of ependymoma that Marila showed in the DNA
methylation
graph that she showed. And you can see that ACORD1 expression is seen in
ZFTA/RELI tumors, and we did not detect in the small cord in these other
molecular subtypes of ependymoma.
So we leveraged a really beautiful
Ayeue model of ZFTA/RELI ependymomas that was described by Ben Deneen and
Steve Mack, and this is the other paper that Maria alluded to that will be coming
up.
And this model is very powerful because the fusion alone,
without any other oncogenes, is able to generate a very aggressive model of
ependymoma. So we did this on three backgrounds.
So we had ACORD1 wild type or ACORD1 whole body knockout,
or a Nestin-Cre ACORD1 where the tumor cells alone
will lose ACORD1. So here are the survival curves.
So in black is the ACORD1 wild type, and you can see that this oncogene is very
powerful. The animals die at median age 25
days. And then here are ACORD1 whole body knockout in
green, and you can see these animals survive really well.
And this is Nestin-Cre where there's knockdown of
ACORD1 within the tumor cells, and you can see that these animals really survive
really well, too. And more importantly, there doesn't seem to be a difference here.
So it's actually not the tumor microenvironment ACORD1 in the whole
body knockout, so it's actually driving this phenotype.
So we're very encouraged by these results.
And then we also wanted to look at pharmacological inhibitors of this.
So right at this time when we were doing these experiments, Frank Pessler from the
University of Hannover published this really beautiful paper in Nature Metabolism
that described this metabolite called citraconate that
competitively inhibits with ACORD1. So we took citraconate.
It doesn't really penetrate well into the cell, so we used a dimethyl ester form
that penetrates into the cell and asked if we inhibit citraconate, can we
achieve similar things as to the genetic knockdown with ACORD1?
So we started off with this, where we took ZFTA/RELI
fusion cells, and then we knocked down ACORD1, or we
treated them with this dimethyl citraconate, the inhibitor of ACORD1.
And just as the functional studies, we used RNA-seq as an outline.
So we're very surprised to see that the fusion level transcript
itself droppedSo here I'm plotting the fusion
levels here, and here is empty vector.
Here is the CFTR-RELI. So you see higher fusion levels in this.
This is DMSO and similar to the CFTR-RELI.
But when you treat them with dimethylcitraconate ACORD1, the
fusion mRNA levels drop. And you can also revalidate this in a
patient-derived cell line. So when you treat with this inhibitor of
ACORD1 or you knock down ACORD1, you see mRNA levels of the fusion drop.
So does this also relate to protein levels?
So here are blots, and to remind you, when you blot for RELI, the higher
molecular weight is the fusion, and the lower molecular weight is endogenous RELI.
And you can see in all these conditions with shACORD1
or treating with dimethylcitraconate, you see that the fusion levels are dropping.
So this was very
surprising to us that there's a metabolite or an enzyme that you could
target that directly regulates the fusion level.
So we actively pursued this.
And so we also wanted to validate this in vivo.
And right around this time, another inhibitor came out that's very similar to
citraconate in structure. So we took animal models, and then we
treated them with this inhibitor.
And if this was specific, we wanted to see if we could outcompete this inhibitor by
just injecting itaconate IV to these mouse models.
I did not think it'd work, but actually, it worked really beautifully.
So here we're plotting the tumor fold change.
In black are vehicle-treated animals.
In blue are ACORD1 inhibitor, and then in red is ACORD1 inhibitor,
and now we're treating these animals with itaconate.
So you can see there's a rescue in tumor phenotype.
This also resulted in a rescue in the fusion levels in vivo.
So here are vehicle-treated. These are three different animals, and you can blot
for RELI. This is the higher molecular weight fusion.
If you treat with the ACORD1 inhibitor, the fusion levels go down, and you can
rescue this phenotype in vivo by adding back itaconate to these animals.
So we have in vivo validation of this, too.
So the conclusion from these experiments were, if you antagonize
itaconate production either through ACORD1 or pharmacological inhibitors,
it actually lowers CFTR-RELI fusion expression, and this is both at the
mRNA levels as well as the protein levels.
So we wanted to delve deeper into the mechanisms of this.
And the first thing we thought about is, is this an epigenetic mechanism?
And the rationale for this was the mRNA levels of the fusion itself were going
down.
So to delve more into this,
there was a paper that suggested that itaconate structure is very
similar to alpha-ketoglutarate.
So here is the structures of alpha-ketoglutarate in green and then itaconate in
red here. And this paradigm of an onco-metabolite is what
we were inspired by. So I've told you before that
metabolites that are similar in structure to alpha-ketoglutarate can
outcompete these
alpha-ketoglutarate functions to result in hypermethylation of DNA and histone
methylation. So we postulated or hypothesized that itaconate
behaves like an onco-metabolite, and here, because it's driving fusion
expression to sustain fusion expression.
So if it was driving something, we started looking at activation marks, and
the first mark we looked at is histone H3K4 trimethylation.
This is an activating mark that sits at promoters.
So if you took CFTR-RELI cells, they have high 4 trimethylation
and empty vector if you just compare this low 4 trimethylation.
If you now add itaconate to these cells in a dose-dependent fashion, you see an
increase in H3K4 trimethylation levels here.
You can do the opposite experiment, where you can knock down ACORD1 or treat them
with dimethylcitraconate, and you can see that the H3K4 global
methylations drop. So this is sort of fitting into this paradigm that itaconate
is acting like a onco-metabolite, where if you
treat it, you increase-- If you treat cells with this, you increase methylation,
and if you inhibit it, it drops.
So to do this, to actually further prove this, we actually
did some enzyme kinetic assays, and we treated
cells with positive controls, D2HG or L2HG.
And to remind you, L2HG, the L isoform, is more potent than the D.
We used these as positive controls, and then we treated cells with itaconate as
well, and we did these in vitro kinetic assays.
So here, if I could draw your attention to the IC50s with the positive
control, L2HG inhibits around 470 micromolars.
And you can see itaconate is very similar in potency to inhibit this enzyme,
this lysine demethylase that specifically demethylates
H3K4. 2HG is also inhibiting, but it's less potent than this.
So we're really surprised to see that itaconate has similar potency to
L2HG, suggesting that it does act as an onco-metabolite.
To further prove this, if itaconate is inhibiting KDM5, we should be
able to capture the same phenotype by using a KDM5 inhibitor.
And we used this inhibitor, CPI-455, and we ran this competing
experiment. So again, we're blotting for CFTR-RELI.
The higher molecular weight is CFTR-RELI. The lower is endogenous RELI.
If you treat the cells with DMSO, you see fusion expression, and mesaconate
is a control. It's similar to itaconate, but it doesn't behave like itaconate.
So this is the control showing that there's no change.
And we're doing this experiment where we're treating the cells with
dimethylcitraconate, keeping this concentration constant,
but increasing levels of this KDM5 inhibitor.
And the idea is that the KDM5 inhibitor and itaconate should result in the
same increase in fusion. And that's what we see.
The more CPI inhibitor that you have, you see an increase in the fusion
expression, further validating that itaconate is behaving like an
onco-metabolite. And we did further validation studies, which I'm not going to
share with you for the lack of time.
But the conclusion from these experiments was that itaconate behaves like an
onco-metabolite, increases H3K4 trimethylation.
We actually mapped out the promoter-like region of the fusion
to actually drive the CFTR-RELI fusion.
So can we use this therapeutically?
So we did a similar experiment where we took our IOE models and treated
these mice intravenously with dimethylcitraconate, and it
recapitulated the ACORD1 knockout, where we saw really good survival
benefit with citraconate.These mice also spontaneously
develop spinal metastasis in this H&E section.
You can see this metastatic tumor in the spine.
But when you treat it with dimethyl itaconate, we didn't see a single animal of
the seven that develops spinal metastasis, suggesting in early data that
citraconate is able to abrogate this metastatic phenotype.
Now, citraconate is a tool compound, so translation is
potentially difficult for this. So we then went back,
took a step back, and said: What are the
metabolic pathways that are leveraged to make itaconate?
And from some metabolic tracing studies, we identified glutamine.
Glutamine provides four of the carbons in itaconate.
Itaconate is a five-carbon metabolite, so four of the carbons come from glutamine.
So we thought, can we inhibit glutamine metabolism to now
lower itaconate levels? And I'm showing you some of the data here.
If we inhibit glutamine metabolism using this compound, GHU 083,
which is a glutamine antagonist, you can see a similar drop in the fusion
level. So what we're doing is, again, this RelA blot, and this is the higher
molecular weight. You can
mimic this by using this glutamine antagonist, and the fusion levels drop.
The survival curve is also very similar.
If you take animals that are vehicle-treated versus glutamine antagonist
treatment, you can see there's a survival benefit in these animals as well in
the IuE immune intact models.
So from these data,
we concluded that inhibiting ACOD1 or glutamine is therapeutic in
these animal models.
So I think I'm going to summarize what I've told you so far.
So first, we identified that the ZFT Rel Ependymomas
made this immunomodulatory metabolite that has been described extensively in
macrophages but not in tumors, called itaconate.
Itaconate inhibition actually lowered the fusion
levels in vitro and in vivo, and this was both at the
genetic level and at the pharmacological level, providing maybe a
really interesting mechanism to pursue to directly target the fusion
protein itself.
And then the mechanism that we stumbled on is that itaconate behaves like an
oncometabolite. Because of its similar structure to alpha KG, it inhibits
histone demethylases, specifically what we looked at is KDM5,
and increases this activation mark to drive fusion expression.
And if we could target this pathway either with a tool compound, dimethyl
itaconate, or an upstream glutamine antagonist, this
created a survival benefit in these IuE immune intact models.
So we proposed this model where ZFT Rel fusions
upregulate ACOD1, and this ACOD1, in turn,
is required to drive this fusion by itaconate production.
And itaconate can be supplied by glutamine to produce
itaconate. And there's a positive feedback loop where itaconate
behaves as an oncometabolite, increases this activating
mark at the ZFTA regulatory element, and there's a
positive feedback loop. And you can interrupt this positive feedback loop at
two nodes that I showed you, either at the ACOD1 node by genetic
knockdown or using these two different inhibitors that we used,
or with an upstream GHU 083 that has been used in clinical trials in
adults. And you can interrupt this pathway by decreasing
the fusion levels itself. So I
think
as Mariella alluded to, there's no treatments for these children except radiation,
so there's potential promise to think of ideas of leveraging this
pathway. And then finally, I wanted to give a shout-out to the Cat Car
Pediatric Brain Tumor Center at the University of Michigan.
We're a growing group of right now 10 labs that work on different
aspects of pediatric brain tumors, and this is our holiday party.
So I welcome you to come look at our center and potentially join us.
Thank you so much for your time, and I'd love to take some questions.
That was a great talk, Jurum. Really fantastic work.
Thank you.
Have you started looking at cell state shifts under this therapeutic pressure,
especially not seeing metastases?
I wonder if you-
Yeah
... not getting towards neuronal but towards ependymal.
Yeah. No, it's a very good question, Mariella.
So we recently did your amazing paper at Journal Club, and
we're now looking at if you knock down ACOD1, and then you treat them with
dimethyl itaconate. From our RNA seq., if we overlap them with your data sets
and Steve Mack's data sets, is there a specific cell type that we're targeting?
So initially, we saw a lot of these neural differentiation
pathways, but-
Yeah
... we're just starting to look at that.
So I'll be reaching out to you soon to see.
There's a really interesting
question that you allude to, right?
All these cells have the fusion. So these cell states seem to be
agnostic of the fusion. So probably, like you alluded to, it's something in the
microenvironment that drives them in different ways, right?
I don't think we're fully recapitulating that in a dish, but it's really
interesting to see if you get rid of the fusion,
is the fusion contributing to any of those cell states?
Yeah. It's so cool. Let me know what you find-
Yeah, definitely
... because the fusion levels alone are different in different cell types.
Absolutely.
I didn't get into that.
Yeah. No, absolutely. Yeah.
About to.
Fantastic question. Thank you.
I had a question about the model where you delete ACOD1, I think.
So 50% of the mice survive, but
in the sort of just the straightforward electroporation model, they all die.
Mm-hmm.
So why do only half of the mice die?
Yeah.
So why do half survive? Is there a sex difference?
No, it's really interesting. So we're not powered enough to look at sex
differences, and Michael's beautiful work in PFA ependymomas might suggest there
is. So we've not looked at those mice specifically, but we've done
to see what happens when you treat them with dimethyl
itaconate, and then you remove the treatment. So the fusion comes up immediately.
So we're wondering ifMaybe there is
some sort of real static effect on H3K4 trimethylation where it's able to
dial up or dial down, but that's the current hypothesis.
But it's a really important question as to why.
And in our in vivo models, we're only getting rid of one allele
of ACOD1 because it's floxed at only one allele, so there is still one allele of
ACOD1. So maybe that's enough to drive tumor in 50% of
the animals. But great question.
But they're not male or females that have survived?
We have not looked. So when we separate by sexes, we're not seeing any
difference, but we're not powered to really ask that.
Okay. Thank you.
Kim Stegmeyer from Dana-Farber. Really interesting work.
Thank you.
In one of your earlier figures where you showed ACOD1 expression
across fusion and then non-fusion subsets, it looked like some of
the fusion-positive
samples actually did not have high ACOD1.
Do you have a sense yet of what-
Yeah
... distinguishes those?
Yeah.
Beautiful question, Kim, big fan of your work.
So like Mariella said, the amount of fusion that's expressed in tumor
cells is very variable, right? So we did a correlation between
ACOD1 levels and tumor levels, and it's like a straight line, right?
And
I didn't get data to show you this, but
macrophages use
NF Kappa B signaling to actually drive ACOD1 expression.
So it's potentially possible that the RELA portion of
the fusion is actually driving these cells to make ACOD1.
So there seems to be a direct dependence on the amount of fusion in
ACOD1. Yeah.
And then what's known about what regulates the level of expression
of the fusion?
It's a really beautiful question.
If you ask me to speculate, it could be the 4-trimetyl levels,
but there's thoughts about DNA
methylation as well. And since you study fusion tumors as well, I think this is a
question in fusion because I was trying to read up on this, and I don't
find a clear answer as to what actually regulates fusion transcript levels.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. I have another question. I guess it's more related to the
microenvironment because you just mentioned that
itaconate, it's also related to the macrophage functioning.
So I just wonder, is this metabolite just restricted in the tumor
cells, or it can also be released to the microenvironment and how that can
change-
No, it's a really important question.
So this metabolite is thought to be anti-inflammatory.
So if you challenge mice with LPS or infections, it's produced in
those conditions. There's not a lot of work done in tumor-associated
macrophages. It's thought to be down-regulated in tumor-associated macrophages
because it's up-regulated in the opposite pathway in inflammatory cells, right?
There's not a lot of work done because of that in the tumor microenvironment, but
it's still early work. There's a paper in preprint to suggest that in
breast cancer models, ACOD1 inhibition within the microenvironment may have
some role, but it's a really important question that people have not really looked
at in detail.
Got it. Thank you.
All right. Well, thank you everyone for your attention.
Okay, so I'm going to talk about something different, which is to
do with immunology,
and particularly about reversing brain tumor immunotolerance, and it might
be a broader approach than just for this particular type of disease we're
talking about today. These are my disclosures.
So I usually use this slide to start talks like this.
And you've heard a lot about how over the years, my lab and other labs
have mapped transcriptomic similarities between normal
lineages in the developing brain using the mouse as a model of mammalian
development. And showing that those transcriptome patterns match
different kinds, classes of clinically relevant
tumor types in children.
But actually, I also show this because all we ever really did was
replicate the work of two incredible people who were working in the northeast of
the
US, Harvey Cushing and Percival Bailey, about 100 years ago, who did
all of this with the back of an envelope and a microscope.
And it just reminds us that the great work that they've done essentially
just stands the test of time.
But what they couldn't do was ask a question
I've had for a long time, which is why are tumors
tolerated in children? So if they are born in utero, and
although they don't produce them at particularly high rates, they generate
neoantigens constantly. What is the mechanism by which that's
tolerated? And indeed, what's the mechanism by which a child learns that
its own brain belongs to it? So if I took John's kidney out today and
put it in me, I'd get arrested, but I'd probably reject it as well
because I would recognize it as John's and not mine.
So there must be a point at which the brain recognizes or the child recognizes
the brain belongs to it. And this is all the work of Elizabeth Cooper, who's a
fantastic postdoc in my lab.
And she asked that question, is first of all, why is the normal brain
tolerated? And then does that relate to childhood brain tumors?
And when I went to medical school 100 years ago, with many of you in the
room, the brain had no immune system.
It just lived behind this castle wall.
It had this sort of what we call the immunoprivileged site.
And we know over work from many labs, not my lab, but from many
labs over the last five years or so, actually, that's completely untrue.
And there's incredibly rich immune system in the brain, which, it
basically is governed by the calvarial bone marrow, with a
complete hematopoietic stem cell system in there.
And also, there are bony channels passing through the skull through which CSF and
signal mechanisms can pass. And they communicate to
maintain a very rich immune system within the brain, which basically
educates, and we think the child,
to basically the brain being self.
And that's really what Elizabeth set out to
ask.So the first question that Elizabeth had is
by removing white cells that were circulating, so immune cells that were
circulating from the rest of the mouse, what does the
immune system or immune repertoire look like in the normal developing brain and
in a tumor? And this is for me a really stunning result, probably my favorite
result that Elizabeth generated.
And that is looking at,
these are all immune repertoire cells from a normal mouse
without a brain tumor and a littermate that has a tumor.
And what you can recognize almost immediately after birth, there's a complete loss
of a whole series of these cells, which not only persist if there's a brain tumor
present, but actually expand. And these,
I characterized particularly a large proportion of them by being LSK positive
and being hematopoietic-like stem cells in nature.
So the first question she asked is, okay, these cells that are resident, are
they truly hematopoietic stem cells?
And so to do that, she isolated these cells from a brain tumor, and then
using busulfan conditioning,
she then transplanted these cells back into the periphery of mice
and demonstrated that you could reconstitute all of the immune
repertoire in these conditioned mice.
And they constituted all of the cell types.
So they truly are hematopoietic stem cells.
But what I skipped over in the first slide is that they're also MHC
II class positive, which is an unusual state.
Had it previously be, this has been described in the peripheral bone marrow of
patients with AML.
But seeing these in the tumor suggests not only are they hematopoietic stem cells,
but they might also be antigen-presenting.
So if these are being governed by the tumor, some of the tumor is somehow
retaining this embryonic state I showed you early on, and it's actually
instructing the bone marrow to retain this hematopoietic
stem cell. Could that be happening through the CSF?
And so to address that, what Elizabeth did first of all was to establish that there
is indeed a communication between the CSF and the skull bone marrow.
And to do that, she injected anti C-kit, so hematopoietic stem cell
recognizing antibodies into the CSF, and then harvested
bone marrow out of the skull. And in the presence of a tumor, there's an
increase in these cells in the skull, not in the tibia.
And that's associated with increase in CD45 positive cells.
She also showed using this OVA488, there's also an increase
in the ability for that particular protein to be recognized by the
immune population within the hematopoietic stem cells within the
skull, calvarium bone marrow.
So there's a mechanism by which CSF can flow to the skull,
and you can see that mechanism in the presence of tumors also
labeling hematopoietic stem cells. But is it the CSF that's doing that?
So to do that, she did a series of CSF transfer experiments where
she took CSF out of the mice that had a
brain tumor, so harvesting CSF from mice that had a tumor, and
harvested CSF from mice that didn't have a tumor from littermates,
and then basically transferred that CSF into completely normal
mice.
And in just doing that, she was able to show an increase with
tumor-derived CSF, an increase in these
hematopoietic stem cells in the dura, not so much in the skull, but
mainly in the dura where these cells reside, and I'll show you that in a minute.
But also an increase in other cell types, including
B-cells as well as T-cells.
So there seems to be a mechanism by these tumors are communicating
through the CSF, and actually there's some aspect of the CSF, which I'll come to in
a minute, which is allowing this signal to instruct the hematopoietic
stem cells in the bone marrow. But where do they reside?
Well, she's demonstrated that they leave the hematopoietic stem cell niche within
the skull, and they reside in these next to the
superior sinuses and the transverse sinuses, creating these sort
of nodules, almost like organized B-cell
collections and hematopoietic stem cell connections adjacent to blood vessels,
both in the presence of tumor as shown here, but also
absent or reduced in the absence of tumor.
And what was remarkable is these hematopoietic stem cells themselves seem to
position themselves across the lateral veins, which come off from the
sinuses, almost as if they're in a state to sample what is being
presented to them in this mechanism.
So if these are truly hematopoietic stem cells that
have this sort of mechanism to actually exist
in the skull and then egress and enter into the brain into
tumor, are they indeed hematopoietic stem cells that are antigen presenting?
Because obviously she's shown that they're MHC II positive.
So to address that, she made use of this e alpha peptide
mechanism. So this is an abnormal protein which can be
taken up by antigen presenting cells, and when presented in the context of
MHC II, can be recognized by the YAE antibody.
So it allows you to actually see that there's MHC II presentation going
on. So to do that again, what she did is inject these antigens
into the CSF and then harvest cells out from the skull bone marrow,
and then look for the presence of binding with the YAE
antibody. Also, you can use this DQ OVA
protein, which is an autofluorescence once it's cleaved.
So also to look to see if there are proteins being taken up by these
hematopoietic stem cells, which they would do to antigen present.
Basically, what she was able to show is that these hematopoietic stem cells in the
skull are just as good at antigen presenting as
professional antigen presenting cells such as dendritic cells.
So what becomes of these cells when they generate...
So when the basically neoantigens are moving from the CSF
into the skull, and then you're being activated and uptaken by these
hematopoietic stem cells.
So in the mechanism that I'll describe now, I'm not going to show you all
the in vitro work that she did. But essentially, what she was able to demonstrate
that there's a direct interaction between CD4 positive T-cells and
these antigen presenting hematopoietic stem cells.Now, the fate
of the antigen-presenting hematopoietic stem cells is they actually progress down a
myeloid lineage, which is very
immunosuppressing. So they have an increase in
myeloid cells in the presence of a tumor, an increase in these
GMP-positive cells.
Conversely, on the other side, the CD4 positive T-cells actually go down a
Treg lineage, which is also, many of you will be aware, immunosuppressing
and marked by Fox P3.
So this presents a sort of paradigm which is perhaps targetable.
And so
what Elizabeth did, and I'm not going to show you for time, is she looked very
carefully at the proteome profiling in the presence of a tumor and the absence of
tumor. And the particular cytokine that is upregulated in
CSF in the presence of tumor is GM-CSF, which many will be
familiar,
granulocyte myeloid
colony-stimulating factor. And there's large amounts of this in the
CSF of mice that have tumors. And that's interesting, which I'll show you in a
minute. So the paradigm is that these tumors are basically
secreting large amounts of this to CSF.
They're passing through these channels to educate hematopoietic stem cells in the
bone marrow. That themselves, through this interaction with CD
positive T-cells, are producing Tregs, but
also these myelo-suppressing cells which infiltrate the tumor, which actually
pack these tumors and suppress any CD8 positive
T-cells from there.
Now, the reason that's interesting is because there's an antibody called
Lenzilumab. There have been many anti-GM-CSF antibodies produced over the
years. Most of them are now on the shelf, they're not in the clinic, but
Lenzilumab is still in the clinic.
And we had the concept that you could actually give intrathecal doses of
Lenzilumab and actually block GM-CSF signaling, and that might have a
therapeutic effect.
That's what I'm showing you here in these three animal models.
So this is an animal model that we've generated of ZFT-RelA
ependymoma. So it's not an electroablation model.
It's a spontaneous genetically modified mouse model.
Similarly, from a choroid plexus carcinoma model that we've made and also an
aggressive model of group three medulloblastoma.
So three very aggressive different brain tumor models.
And the same thing happens when you inject anti-GM-CSF antibody
into here. First of all, the CSF concentration of
GM-CSF itself falls. There's also a decrease in
proliferation of hematopoietic stem cells in the skull, also a
reduction in myeloid cells in the tumor, and an increase in
CD8 positive T-cells in the tumor.
And this is associated in all models with a marked regression of
tumor cells, both in the ZFT-RelA ependymoma, CPC, and
ependymoma model.
Now, what happens subsequently to this is these tumors will all relapse.
And as you might imagine, the CD8 positive T-cells exhaust.
However, if you add a checkpoint inhibitor with this, you get prolonged
remissions.
So the other question Elizabeth had is, because these are residing in the
skull bone marrow, could this antibody be delivered intravenously
rather than intrathecally? Because obviously therapeutically, that'd be much more
convenient for using in children,
because you'd have to have a myo reservoir in place to use that.
And in fact, you get exactly the same results if you just give an intravenous
injection delivery of this antibody.
So this looks like a really potent way of
potentially treating these tumor types.
But also potentially, you can imagine this might be an adjuvant treatment
with a CAR T-cell therapy, which almost certainly is going to be suppressed in the
same mechanism as endogenous CD8 positive T-cells.
So this is going to be going to clinical trial with our friends at Dana-Farber and
Baylor College of Medicine in GOS and also in
Australia. And we're delighted that Taryn Therapeutics, who have Lenzilumab, are
going to give us the antibody for free for this trial.
So the last thing I added on was just a really, sort of for me,
sort of the holy grail for brain tumors when I started working on these 40 years
ago, is would it ever be possible to get an
immunization? Could we actually immunize against children's brain tumors?
And so there's a lot of work going on.
We're collaborating with Brandon Wainwright and others on RNA vaccines, which
obviously had their particular explosion in technology during the COVID
period.
But we're interested in a very different aspect.
So I've always been interested in the gut-brain axis.
I know that sounds very hippy if you work on the microbiome and stuff, but actually
there's a very serious aspect of the gut-brain axis, which
was really uncovered by Mena Clatworthy and other people around the lab.
And Mena is an immunologist at Cambridge, which is one of the fantastic things
about working there. And what Mena demonstrated is that probably as an
evolutionary mechanism, we've evolved a mechanism for
if you're actually as a multi-organ species, being exposed to nasty
things that can damage you, the most likely area that will be is
either through the skin or through the gut when you're ingesting
things. And so a mechanism has evolved that Mena's
proved, where antigens which are taken up into the gut, get
educated in Peyer's patches, particularly T-cells,
by being presented antigens in the gut.
And those cells can then migrate directly to the brain and actually protect the
brain and get incorporated into the immune axis within the brain.
And the way that Mena's particularly demonstrated this is by developing a
vaccine for Listeria monocytogenes, which is the meningitis
bacteria which causes the soft cheese-related problems for pregnant
women in terms of infection.
But we had an idea, rather than using this for meningitis, could we use this
against the fusion?
So we generated a series of peptides which will be immunogenic
around the junction between ZFT and RelA that you've heard a lot about today.
And the way this mechanism works is that you take your peptide of interest,
and obviously Mena had used peptides that were from Listeria
monocytogenes, and we generate DNA fragments for this.
And then you strip out of Salmonella, so a very potent
infecting agent, you can strip out the pathogenic elements of
that and instead put in your elements to target
for immune response, in this case, the fusionSo
then you can transfer that as an oral vaccine just like we use a polio vaccine.
So you take these bacteria that are non-pathogenic but carrying the antigen,
and then you can dose mice. And this is my penultimate slide.
So we just generated this, and this is mice that received two different oral
vaccines against Salmonella typhimurium,
fusion 10 or fusion 19 peptides, or
control M. Salmonella. And this is just showing tumor growth in the
brain. And a remarkable response to two doses
of an oral Salmonella vaccine.
And these mice actually have tumors present.
So this is actually treating active disease.
We wait until the disease is established.
But obviously the
long-term dream of this is this might be an oral vaccine for
patients who have not got brain tumors.
Could we include this along with diphtheria, tetanus, and polio?
Obviously, this is a dream at the moment.
But you might say, "Well, what about other brain tumor types?" So working with
Brandon Wainwright in the US, we've looked at a whole series of neoantigens.
And actually, it turns out in patients who develop ependymomas or
medulloblastomas or other tumor types, and John's probably more of an
expert on this than I am in neuroblastoma, actually many of those patients will
have common neoantigens. So the idea is, can we generate a battery
of neoantigens that we could introduce into these Salmonella
bacteria and then give this as an oral vaccine?
So essentially, we began the session talking about how these tumors
basically generate from normal lineages in the brain, and they pass
through to generate basically remnants of embryonic tissue.
But I think what these remnants of embryonic tissue do as a consequence is also
keep the brain in an embryonic state.
They keep the brain immune system in an embryonic state.
And just as the child has learned to tolerate its own brain, it thinks it
needs to tolerate this abnormal tissue as well because it's embryonic, it's always
been there. So if we can break that immunotolerance, either through
using the approaches I showed you with anti-GM-CSF, or even
exploit that immune system to actually target it
using cells that are sensitized in the gut, we may well have a
completely different way of treating these tumors that's not relying on
chemotherapy, radiation, or surgery.
So with that, I'm going to thank my lab.
I'll be happy to take any questions, and then I think we've got time for more
questions as well. So thank you very much for your attention.
Great talk, Richard, as always. So I have one question
regarding the first part of your talk, the antibody, but it
worked so well for
ependymoma and medullo. I just
wonder if you have also tried the
DIPG tumor because it's more lethal.
Yeah, we don't work on DIPG, but what Elizabeth has done is
she's taken en bloc resections from adults and
children. The other question we get is, will this work in adults?
Mm-hmm.
And actually, so that's the skull dura and underlying brain tumor and
brain from a resection. And actually, we see exactly the same repertoire of
cells in patients who have gliomas, including children.
So we think this may well operate in that same system, but we've not tested it.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Thanks.
Hey, Richard.
Hi, John.
Thanks for organizing this. All three talks were great. Thanks very much.
So the
MHC II HSCs, that's a really interesting story.
Yeah.
And it's nice that you validated with OVA and that.
But have you or have anyone looked to see actually what
peptides are presented and if they're different in the brain tumor
situation than in the normal marrow niche where you would understand
why you'd want some immunosuppression against in the stem cell compartment?
Yeah, that's a great question, John.
So we have validated, I didn't show it today for time,
with the fusion itself. So the fusion itself can get
presented in the same mechanism. What we haven't
done is that detailed immunopeptidomics
to look across to see whether it's the fusion itself that's being presented in the
context of the tumor. We said that you can introduce the fusion through the
CSF, and it will get presented. But whether that's the sole
antigen that's being presented in the context of the tumor, if that was the
question, we haven't done that.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm confused then. So these are the derived from
the bone marrow of the skull, and how do they have the fusion?
Oh, so the fusion is secreted into the CSF.
I see.
So it's fragmented and secreted into the CSF.
And so Elizabeth introduced the fusion fragments into the CSF and shown that they
can be presented.
They're picked up by the stem cells and then-
In the skull bone marrow.
So they're in the hematopoietic stem cell niche in the bone marrow, but they also
exist mainly in the dura as well. So they exist both in the
hematopoietic stem cell niche in the skull but also in the dura itself.
And what's really interesting is, I haven't got time to talk, it's a separate
story, where they actually form...
There's also B cells, pro-B cells, and immature B cells in
lymphoid clusters within the dura in the presence of a tumor.
So you're reconstituting this completely abnormal immune system in the
dura itself, which almost seems as important as the skull.
Yeah. I do think you have a beautiful system to do the immunopeptidomics and just
see what's there.
Oh, you can help us if you want because it's not what we do, but that'd be great.
Thanks.
Thank
you for a beautiful talk. As a non-immunologist
but a geneticist-
Well, that makes two of us
... as a geneticist, I kept thinking about retinoblastoma, right?
Yeah.
So there's a tumor that literally is growing in the retina.
Mm.
May be more protected and doesn't have a fusion.
Yeah.
Just has loss. So do you imagine the same kind of
immune tolerance?
I've talked to a couple of people who work in retinoblastoma who asked me the same
question. I don't know the answer to that because we don't know whether,
as you say, the retina is a protected system, whether that is exposed in the same
way. We think probably not.But we have no evidence for
that. The sense that CSF is separate from the internal
aspects of the retina means it probably isn't, but we don't have any evidence for
that.
Well, people have now started to look in CSF, and they can see the
mutant RB1.
Yeah.
But I don't know how far along the patient has to be.
So there's also no fusion, right? So what the
antigen's going to be is also a little less clear.
That's right. And also, the penetration of these systems is bizarre.
So people, as you know, probably are looking in tears as well.
They can find from brain tumors, not that it's the same anatomic connection,
evidence from the proteomics of tumors present in the brain.
Now, whether that's a secondary mechanism,
but the anatomic proximity makes you wonder whether there is more of a connectivity
there.
Thank you.
Hello. Thank you for the fascinating talk.
And this is Samya from Memorial Sloan Kettering.
I was wondering, what
is the state of the macrophages that
come down the lineage from the hematopoietic stem cells?
How differentiated are they?
I don't know how differentiated they are.
So it's basically there is a myeloid suppressing element to those
cells.
Whether they are, I know we can't call them M1 or M2 macrophages anymore, but
whether they're activated, so are they active or inactivated?
We do see activated macrophages within the tumor
population. But these are a separate type of myeloid
suppressing type cell, and also a dominance of Tregs as well in the tumor
cell, which seems to be slightly different from that.
Again, so Jerry, who's at the back, who knows more about this than I do,
he's looking at these in all the tumors in our mouse models,
including choroid plexus carcinomas, and other types of ependymomas.
So we do see differences in the macrophage population and
the microglia populations, which does seem to be
associated with tumor type.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So, Richard, following up on that.
Oh, hey.
So you didn't talk about the kind of resident microglia,
the entire part of that immune system.
Is it talking to these
CSF2 skull bone marrow?
Yeah, that's a really great question.
Thanks, Mark. So,
this system, at least, whether it communicates, it's very possible
that we've not looked directly at the communication with endogenous microglia.
We do know that the microglia are very active and
present in different formats, in different tumor types.
And that, as I mentioned, that's Jerry's work.
In fact, we're doing a study at the moment to see if we can deplete microglia and
what the impact that is on tumor genesis, because there are various inhibitors
which you can do that with.
Whether that ultimately affects this axis, I don't know the answer to
that. Whether the hematopoietic stem cell axis is interacting with those microglia,
I don't know. I don't know if we've looked at that directly.
Great.
Great talk.
Is the CD34 MHC Class 2
come because of the tumors?
Ah.
So have you done this in vitro where you could actually take normal hematopoietic
stem cells, and what is the normal physiological role, I think, of these specific
CD34 MHC Class 2 positive?
Yeah, that's a really good question.
So as I showed right at the beginning, which is why I think it's the most beautiful
piece of work, is that actually, so my bias has always
been is that tumors never invent anything new.
They just
use existing processes. And actually, the reason why we were able to map right at
the--
decades ago, the origin of ependymomas, because a lot of the cells as
also Mariella shown, look very like endogenous brain
tumor cells, normal cells during development.
So as you saw right at the beginning, actually, the immune profile that
exists in a tumor is really indistinguishable from that that's present in the
normal embryonic brain. It just persists.
So they are present in utero and for about two days
postnatally, and then they disappear.
So the concept is that these are the cells involved in
recognizing self. So self-antigens are actually
passing during development through the CSF, through the skull into, and
educating the hematopoietic stem cells to what are self-proteins.
And that's why we think if they are also receiving fusion fragments, they
recognize that as self, and they therefore don't reject the brain tumor.
So if you inject these things into syngeneic, you're actually producing them.
So there are factors that are produced that convert the hematopoietic stem cells
in the skull into this format, correct?
Sorry, say that again.
For the syngeneic models that you showed.
Yeah.
Once you inject the tumors, these cells appear also in the
skull?
Yeah. So what we've done is we've transferred the CSF
itself-
Right
... which will be carrying neoantigens and carrying the cytokines
into the CSF. And what they do is, I don't know whether they
reappear, but presumably, they expand a
small fragment of this.
That's what I'm saying. Is it the cytokine or is it just new antigens that's
expanding?
It's both. I think it's both.
Although they would not have been sensitized previously.
Correct.
But I do think it helps us understand why I think this operates in adults, because
I don't think these cells disappear completely.
So one thing we're looking at at the moment with Mena in
neurodegeneration, but also in the context of immunity, whether this is a
resident population that stays, and they expand in the context of threats
like degeneration or infection.
Thank you.
So, quick question to you. Oh, I'm sorry.
You said that it also works with medulloblastoma?
Yes. Group 3 medulloblastoma.
Have you looked at the other groups, like the sonic hedgehog, the
No. At the moment, we just wanted to see--
Why would you invent this just for ependymomas, right?
And because it's a normal process, we think, then it probably is resident and
active in all tumor types. So the reason we
picked Group 3 medulloblastoma, it's aggressive.
It comes from probably a stem-like cell in the hindbrain, although we don't know
particularly which cell type.
Right.
Group 3, so ZFT or ependymoma because it's a forebrain tumor with a different
lineage. And then CPCs come from choroid plexus.
So they're very different lineages, very different tumor types, very different
genetic burdens. So CPCs have completely
disorganized genomes, less so in the ZFT or LEA
ependymomas. So this was really to cover the waterfront of brain tumor
types. So it's equally active in those three.
And do you think that this could be something you'd use the hedgehog model for
to see if the-
Absolutely. There's no reason why we couldn't do that in a hedgehog.
Certainly, we have the hedgehog model present.
And I can't remember, Jerry, did we look at hedgehog?
I think so.
Yeah. So I think we're looking, so we have the hedgehog model-
Work in progress
... that Matt Scott originally generated. So we're using that one. Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
Okay. So I think if you want to...
Are there any other questions? Rather than drag the two speakers up here and then
for there to be no questions. I mean, we've had a lot of questions, which has been
great. Does anybody have additional questions or comments?
No. If not, then I won't drag the two of you back up here.
But thank you so much for coming. Great to see you all. Thank you so much.